before I show this movie I ate a
chick-fil-a chicken sandwich that was a
mistake
killer Joe is directed by William fried
Kenan stars Matthew McConaughey Emile
Hirsch Juno temple Gina Gershon and
Thomas Haden Church it's a story about
this family in Texas and they're very
poor you know they're totally down and
out because of Emil Hersh's mistakes
he's now into all this debt and he
realizes that his old deadbeat mother
who was terrible with him from birth
that no one likes is worth quite a bit
of money in an insurance policy so he
decides to hire an assassin to kill his
mother so he can collect the money that
assassin is killer Jo and now we have
our movie if you walk into this movie
just know that it is very intense it is
however a really good movie too and the
performances in this movie are terrific
namely one Matthew McConaughey this guy
is having a really good year he was
great in Magic Mike and in my opinion he
is oscar-worthy in this film this is
probably the best performance I've ever
seen for Matthew McConaughey he is scary
he's frightening his imposing he's
extremely intimidating in this movie and
he's riveting every time he's on screen
every time he starts talking you are
absolutely focused on what he's saying
course we never discussed the
possibility of a retainer what do you
mean hey man you talking about my sister
that I she is really every actor in this
movie is on the top of their game Thomas
Haden Church is actually once again
really funny in this movie I thought he
was really funny and we bought a zoo he
was a great comic relief in that movie
this movie had a surprising amount of
humor which kind of added to some of the
more intense sequences and made you feel
awkward about the fact that you were
laughing the film has a really rare
sense of humor and it's that sense of
humor where something is so horrific
that it makes you laugh and that's
extremely hard to find because a lot of
movies when you see stuff it's portrayed
so seriously that you're just like ah
you know oh you know what I mean and
this movie does have a few of those
moments trust me yes it does it's really
hard to explain this without spoiling
anything but since the film has that
humor throughout it makes the tension
kind of diffuse a little bit and that
sounds negative but it's not
actually really added something to the
movie this pranks this movie are the
performances in the direction this is a
really tense movie this director is very
good at that he's made some films in the
past that many considered to be very
controversial very frightening very
scary and here he really brings that to
this movie as well and for this movie I
was really surprised the amount of
tenseness that some of these scenes
built up I mean I actually felt like
some knots in my stomach at times about
what I was thinking could happen or what
might happen in this scene
tuna casserole mr. dreeben come on mama
that's not appropriate dinner
conversation Donnie this film is an
opening and limited release until July
27th and even then it's just going to be
very limited then it'll expand later and
I got seen early screening of it which
is really cool but this film is going to
be really controversial in some ways
because it portrays certain acts without
really explaining all the details so
some questions sometimes pop into your
mind the film doesn't answer and I could
tell that some audience members were
annoyed with that so when the movies
ambiguous in certain ways and it feels
lazy like the writers just couldn't come
up with anything so they decided to just
let certain things happen without really
giving them answers I don't like that
that's dumb this movie wasn't like that
this movie was brave really is the good
word to use it it had courage to do some
of the things they do in this movie and
portray some the things they portray
there are some gaps in the film you have
to fill in for yourself really everyone
in this movie is good but the thing is
they're portraying them like the worst
people ever like you you never want to
meet these people in a few times that
did take away from the movie for me it
wasn't too bad though it was just a few
times in the movie I was like really are
you that depraved I think that horrible
of a person some of the problems with
this movie lie in the script for me a
lot of times in the movie it was a
little bit jumpy when I say that I'm
talking about tone because there are
certain scenes in this movie that are so
well done and so tense and so taut and
then there are others that feel kind of
like a comedy and then of those it feel
like a drama and it's really difficult
really to lock down what genre this
movie is and in a way that's a
compliment but at times it did distract
me from the movie the Matthew
McConaughey was always there just
pulling me and pulling me in with that
performance he may not get recognized
because this isn't one of those movies
like shame for instance Michael
Fassbender did not get any nominations
from the Oscars for that he may not get
recognized
this movie but he deserves it in my
opinion that being said this is an
excellently directed movie very very
frightening at times very funny also
with great performances one Matthew
McConaughey doing very well I'm gonna
give killer Joe a B+ if it comes out
near you and you feel like you can take
a movie that has some interesting
content that's what I'll say then check
it out at least rent the DVD or blu-ray
when it comes out smells heavenly who
would like to say grace and as always
guys if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck my